I am Donald Richards, I am a professor of
statistics at Penn State University
One thing that I would make people
aware of is that in most things in life
you are probably better off staying
close to the middle. yes, in financial
matters you're probably better off
staying close to the middle, not taking
not going on on the extreme edges, in
matters of the heart it would be my
advice to once you've made your choice
give it your best, don't don't be an
average husband or an average friend or
an or an average uncle or what be are
extremely good uncle or an extremely
good friend are an extremely good
husband
extremely good co-author but in most
things you're better off being staying
close to the average that would be my
advice another thing that people should
learn is that in most ventures in life
the odds are against you. So think very
very carefully before you take a venture
and you have to be sure in your mind as
to why exactly you believe that odds are
not against you.